[Hail to the Chief plays]
- GOOD EVENING,
MY FELLOW AMERICANS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED FAITH IN--
- WE WON, MOTHER[bleep]ERS!
[screaming]
WE WON!
- THAT'S MY ANGER TRANSLATOR,
LUTHER.
- WHOO!
YEAH! WHAT'S UP?
[humming]
♪ MM MM-MM MM
♪ MM MM MM-MM
- BUT I WANT TO WISH
MY OPPONENT, MITT ROMNEY, WELL.
HE RAN A GOOD CAMPAIGN.
- TAKE THAT [bleep]
BACK TO THE LAB, MITT,
'CAUSE YOU LOST!
- AND NOW WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH PRESSING ISSUES.
- WE GONNA PASS HEALTHCARE
AGAIN.
NOW WHAT, BITCHES?
- WHILE WE HAD HUGE TURNOUT
FROM OUR FAITHFUL SUPPORTERS...
- THANK YOU, BLACK FOLKS!
WE MADE IT TO TWO ELECTIONS
IN A ROW, MAN!
NOW HOW HARD WAS THAT?
- ALL YOUR VOTES WERE CRUCIAL
IN THIS VICTORY.
- WHITE PEOPLE
WHO VOTED FOR ME,
Y'ALL ARE ALL NOW
HONORARY BLACK PEOPLE.
- SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
- AND [bleep] YOU
IF YOU TRIED TO [bleep] ME!
I MEAN, YOU KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY TRIED TO SPEND
TO GET RID OF THIS?
MILLIONS, SON!
I SAID MILLIONS!
BUT YOU COULDN'T GET RID
OF IT, [bleep].
AW, NAW.
YEAH, CAN'T TOUCH THIS.
- LUTHER.
N--LUTHER,
WHAT'D I TELL YOU?
NO HAMMER DANCING.
- COME ON, "B"!
WE WON!
LET'S DO IT, DOG!
- NO, I'M, UH,
I-I-I TOLD YOU,
I DON'T WANT YOU
DOING IT WRONG.
- OHH.
- YOU GOTTA GET IT RIGHT.
- OHH!
- IF YOU'RE GONNA DO IT--
GOD BLESS AMERICA.
- OH, THAT'S RIGHT,
THAT'S RIGHT.
SAY IT, THOUGH.
SAY IT!
- NOW, I-I-I TOLD YOU, HOMEBOY,
YOU CAN'T TOUCH THIS.